what I'm gonna talk a little bit about
is targets and how companies set those
and give an example and then I'm going
to come back to the last point which is
market friendly or business friendly
environmental policy my sense is that
we've already discussed in the previous
lectures numbers 2 3 & 4 that is measure
value and report your footprint using
and improving tools for biodiversity
management and building biodiversity
business so I'll focus on 1 & 5 and I've
already mentioned some examples of
companies that have set what seemed like
ambitious or sometimes heroic or maybe
aspirational targets with respect to
biodiversity and other ecosystem
services and we can see this pretty much
across the board in in every major
economy and many well-known brands where
companies are making commitments on a
voluntary basis that they don't have to
do and that can sometimes be a stimulus
to to action inside the company and
increase scrutiny from outside the
company the big global institutions and
most of the scientific community
continue to push this line and you see
it again and again in some of the
seminal reports such as the Millennium
ecosystem assessment came out in 2005
talking about not just valuation but
integrating those values into economic
decision-making reforming subsidies
paying for ecosystem services reducing
unsustainable consumption and using a
variety of economic instruments to try
and promote more conservation and
restoration and it might be helpful to
think a little bit about what does that
mean in practice what are we actually
talking about if you boil it down
essentially we're comparing different
practices different types of production
different types of consumption some are
more damaging than others and very
simply what
want to do is to increase the costs of
the unsustainable practice and decrease
the costs of the more sustainable models
and on the flip side we want to reduce
the benefits of the unsustainable
practice and increase the economic
benefits of the the more sustainable
choice and there are a range of
different mechanisms that we can use in
those four different boxes to try and
achieve those increases or decreases in
costs and benefits
you